okay what was the point of getting that
the point is now i can use this thing
right now i know what it is I know I
know how many turn their bar I can just
go ahead and use the foil ok so I'm
going just stop writing this with an N
here because remember I just said that n
is different to this end right so I'm
going to just call this s that's a bit
naughty because usually we indicate that
as a limiting some but here I just want
to avoid saying a different end okay all
right now run this off and now i'm going
to put it on your ipod all the pieces
that I know okay so it's a the first
term which is three bien okay and i've
got 1 minus again the common ratio
appears which is minus 3 to the power of
however many terms are there i'm just
saying that really carefully because
it's not just n in this case right it's
2n plus 1 okay that yep / what's on the
denominator again want to take away the
contrary she likes it are you happy now
you can kind of see why I put it as one
moans are rather than I minus 1 because
this is how I dodged my negative on the
number okay now that's it that's it
really I just need to tidy this up a
little bit how's that what's the best
way to tighten this up or start what's
easy the denominator of course is just
for now I'm going to three the end here
now what's the best way to unpack this
guy I've got a lot of negatives flying
around do you see that Londoners so I
want to try and get rid of however many
negatives I can here's how I'm going to
do it do you see how I've got to the
power 2 n plus 1 right to the power of 2
plus 1 and that plus one on the end what
does it mean it means i've multiplied by
this many times and they don't multiply
by negative 3 one more time do you see
them okay so i'm going to rewrite that
guy at the top n is 1 minus negative 3
to the 2 and x 92 3 that's what that
plus 1 in the index indicates okay so
i'm just trying to be careful with my
index notation here what it means now
the reason why that's useful
is because it allows me to get rid of
one of my negatives do you see that
right I've got negative here and just a
single negative here pulled out so those
two good can go together okay before I
got one question always like 10 so you
can just take it out okay yes in fact
that's about what I'm not to do but I
prefer to make the opposite argument
which is about evenness to get rid of
sides rather than to use oddness which
is you can get confused with on the side
I markets yeah you're exactly right in
fact I'm going to make that argument in
a second okay um all right now I can get
rid of this last day to sign really
easily in exactly the way that was just
subscribing to do them by saying do you
see this going here right just be
careful with you index notation again
let's get this I'll write him at the
front and be lazy rather run the whole
line what's happening in here do you see
that i can write minus 3 to the power 2
n right i can write it as because I'm
squared right cuz I'm squared how many
what's going to happen to these
negatives right every negative is going
to head with another one because i'm
squaring do you see that like if n works
a wolf n with one that's the easy
example and then have negative 3 squared
but if n were like 10 right this is
going to be part of 20 so how many
negative times am I going to have ants
are 20 of them and they're all going to
pair up and cancel off does that make
sense so therefore what I've really got
is just 32 n that's it see that
or i could write it as known to the end
but as you'll see in a second it's in my
interest not to do that because then i
could if i keep the same base then
everything can simplify do okay I'm
ready to write my last line now i think
i'm going to expend out the reason why
it's just so i have less terms flying
around I've got a 3 to the n times 1
just just 3 to the N I've got a 3d n
times 3 times 3 to the 2n now when you
multiply numbers with the same base what
happens to their indices you just add
them right so I've got n plus 1 plus 2n
now say that again n plus 1 plus 2n
that's just three and plus 1 and I've
got a quarter hanging out the front are
you happy with that that's it happy
times we had a labor a little bit to
make sure we knew how many terms there
are but then once you've done that a is
easy nerds r is easy to know you use the
formula okay question is it bad for
leaving a lot of thing is it bad to
leave it here yeah is it bad I'll I
think you can go forgot it generally
tends to be that from here like you
might they may take ok will tell me now
what what's what happens once the Sun
for N equals 10 I don't think it's so
bless you I don't think it's
particularly harder to evaluate it fan
equals 10 this line versus this line I
think you would probably get them up at
this point you've certainly done some
work you haven't just quoted the formula
and then walked away so this line is
definitely better than this line
but I think you should go this line I
think you should uh like I said if you
remember the question we were looking at
with their what was it about there's
about Abel town and the tickets early
and all that kind of thing there were
lots of later working i showed you in
particular as i said look you know what
this line not a hundred percent
necessary but being it's not hard to get
to that line why would you not do it
when it might be something that they put
marks on hey I could very easily like
this there's non-trivial understanding
for linking from here to here right so I
think this editor is better than this it
it's not just another way to write this
answer does not reasons well this is
this is exactly the point maybe is that
is the question depending on how we
marked wrong the question like if you
went on and lets the last time you made
a mistake yep it's still gonna mark for
having them binary uh yeah it's a good
question I'm in the answer is it depends
it depends sometimes you'll get ignore
subsequent error like okay you gotta
hear you made a subsequent care and
we're going to ignore it because you
demonstrated everything we as you know
right yes you do open yourself up but
then again you open yourself up to them
not having simplify to properly which is
also you know so I would say to it okay